[Applause]
you will not know this but I was
supposed to be the first non-student
Speaker for the proposition I've now
been the fourth which means that I now
have to thank all the previous speakers
for making my best points for me and I
find that the reason the main reason now
that I have left to be uh in support of
the motion is that I am so tired of
talking about work culture
that's why it's gone too far more than
anything else and I thanked the other
speakers for making the points for me
because it means I don't have to
reiterate the point that no no free
speech is not some right-wing reframing
of whatever it's the foundation of
Western Civilization upon this
civilization is built and the
enlightenment values that led to it I
don't have to make the point that has
been made by far better people in the
past that the only way to deal with the
problem of racism is to treat people on
the content of their character
and nothing else and the fact that woke
culture seeks to overturn that is a new
form of racism that we must all oppose
it means also I will not use this
opportunity to say I Told You So as
someone who spent the last five years
warning people in the west that if we
continue to erode our culture if we
continue to undermine our confidence in
Western values that our enemies enemies
like Vladimir Putin will seek to
capitalize on it I will not make any of
those points tonight
at all
instead I'm not going to talk to those
of you who already agree with me which I
imagine as most of you
um
I'm not going to talk to you because I
imagine after everything you've heard
tonight you're going to vote for the
proposition I'm going to confess I will
take your vote for granted tonight I am
the labor party and you are the red wall
now I want to talk to those of you who
are woke
and who are open to rational argument
a small minority I accept
because one of the tenets of workness is
of course that your feelings matter more
than the truth but I believe in you I
believe there are those of you here who
are work who are open to rational
arguments so let me make one we are told
that your generation cares more than any
other about one issue in particular and
that issue is climate change
we're told that many of you suffer from
climate anxiety
you wish to save the planet and for
tonight and tonight only I will join you
I will join you in worshiping at the
feet of Saint Greta of climate change
let us all accept right here right now
that we are living through a climate
emergency and our stocks of polar bears
are running extremely low
I join you in this view I truly do now
what are we to do about this huge
problem facing Humanity
what can we in Britain do
we can only do one thing you know why
this country is responsible for two
percent of global carbon emissions which
means that if Britain was to sink into
the sea right now it would make
absolutely no difference to the issue of
climate change you know why because the
future of the climate is going to be
decided in Asia and in Latin America by
poor people who couldn't give a [ __ ]
about saving the planet
no thank you
no thank you
it's going to be decided by poor people
in Asia and Latin America who don't care
about saving the planet you know why
because they're poor
because they're poor I Come From Russia
which is not a poor country it's a
middle-income country 20 of households
in Russia do not have an indoor toilet
what they have is an outdoor toilet and
I don't mean one of those nice poor to
lose that we get here
I don't even mean a Glastonbury portaloo
I mean a wooden Shack with a hole in the
ground the holes are collected fermented
memory of the last 10 000 visits
how many of you are going to go home
tonight and say let's rip out our
bathroom and erect a Siberian [ __ ]
in the back Garden
and if you're not why should they
a hundred and twenty million people in
China do not have enough food
I don't mean that they don't get dessert
I mean they suffer from malnutrition
that means that their immune system is
breaking down because they don't have
enough food
you're not going to get them to stay
poor
imagine Yoshi Jinping the leader of
China
when you were 10 years old
there was a revolution a cultural
revolution in your country and people
came and they put your father in prison
your mother had to denounce him
your sister killed herself
and you no longer enjoying the
protection of your formerly powerful
father
were sent to a village where you lived
in a cave house
and here you are decades later you have
clawed your way
of the bloody and greasy pole of Chinese
politics to be the Undisputed supreme
leader of the very Communist Party
that destroyed your family
and you know that the main thing you
have to do
to survive and to stay in power is to
deliver the one thing
that the people of China want prosperity
economic growth
where do you think climate change ranks
on XI jinping's list of priorities
a third of all children who live in
extreme poverty in the world live in
India
that means they are starving and dying
of preventable disease now
about 15 months ago my wife got pregnant
not me because we're old school
and for nine months we talked about what
a boy would look like
what he might do when he grows up
we looked at baby scans and videos on
YouTube about what the fetus looks like
at nine months and 12 months and 20
months and eventually he was born and he
is this cute little bundle of joy he's
cuter than about eighty percent of
puppies right
now if you said to me
that I had a choice either my son had a
serious risk of starving or dying from a
preventable disease in the next year
or I could press a button
and he would live
he would go to school
he would bring his first girlfriend home
you'd go to university and graduate and
become a work idiot
and then he'd get a job and get married
and have children and become a man
but all I have to do is press this
button and for every day of my son's
life a giant plume of CO2 is going to
get released into the atmosphere now
you're all very young and most of you
are not parents let me tell you
something there is not a parent in the
world who would not smash that button so
hard to hand bled
[Applause]
you are not going to get these people to
stay poor you're not even going to get
them to not want to be richer
and so I put it to you ladies and
gentlemen there is only one thing we can
do in this country to stop climate
change and that is to make scientific
and technological breakthroughs that
will create the clean energy that is not
only clean but also cheap
and the No thank you and the only I want
everyone to get home on time today which
is not going to happen
and the only thing that wokeness has to
offer in exchange is to brainwash Bright
Young Minds like you to believe that you
are victims to believe that you have no
agency to believe that what you must do
to improve the world is to complain
is to protest is to throw soup on
paintings
and we on this side of the house are not
on this side of the house because we do
not wish to improve the world we sit on
this side of the house because we know
that the way to improve the world is to
work is to create it is to build
and the problem with work culture is
that it's trained too many young minds
like yours to forget about that
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]